thanks
uh crystal that's nice
for that very very charitable
introduction uh there's been a title
change but i assure you the content
didn't change it's just that i prepared
my slides
and uh tried to cluster my talk into
themes and i couldn't come up with five
themes so i changed the title
but here's the thesis of what i want to
tell you about the thesis is that
in the last 25 years essentially during
my career as a computer scientist
computing cycles have migrated from
doing work in mainly scientific
computing
and for the enterprise to a world where
most computing is done for consumers
and what this has done to us is
it's transformed the way computing
cycles are consumed
and it begs us to look at
consumer behavior when we think about
algorithm design and computing
and so the theme that i'll strike today
is
is really how does consumer behavior
change our thinking about algorithm
design and at the end
i'll uh in turn how this demands
a deeper interaction between the
techniques and tools we're used to in
mathematics and computer science
and the social sciences which which is a
field that's
largely outside of microeconomics in a
few areas
largely been untouched by the kind of
heavy mathematics that we
bring to bear here okay i was told at
dinner last night that there were no
controversies
at the symposium so i'm going to try and
make these
wild claims and hope that somebody finds
it controversial
uh some of this uh this end
state that i'll talk about really should
echo some of the themes that john
kleinberg
would have talked about uh on wednesday
all right
to set the stage i'm going to begin with
a small warm-up exercise so this is a
simple algorithm i'm going to tell you
about
but it really is one where
something fairly standard is
dramatically
aided by our understanding of human
behavior okay and and the setting is
that of
a connectivity server which is a beast
that you find in in all the internet
companies right
so you have this thing called the web
graph so to give you a sense a web graph
is a graph
with whose nodes are the
pages on the web to a very rough order
think of
the number being 10 to the 11 or 10 to
the 12. okay
the average degree is of the order of 10
okay so so that's the size of the beast
you're dealing with okay
and and the the question that we want to
provide support for is what i'll call
adjacency queries so i give you a node
and i ask you who are the neighbors
okay and this has rich applications all
over the internet industry and certainly
the web search industry okay
and and what i'm going to do is in the
next five minutes
show you a simple scheme for doing this
that
by a metric that i'll point out does it
dramatically better
than than the obvious okay and it really
does
hinge on our understanding of consumer
behavior okay all right
so so let's say each url is represented
by an integer and for the purposes of a
running example
think of only four billion pages on the
web although i did tell you a moment ago
that
it's really about 20 or 30 times that
number okay but
that gives you a nice round 32 bits per
node okay
so to represent an edge to write down an
edge that goes from a to b
would in the simplistic way take you 64
bits
okay all right so what i'll show you is
a scheme that achieves about three bits
per edge and it's a really simple scheme
okay so that represents a dramatic
almost two orders of magnitude savings
on the obvious
and what this really hinges on is
understanding how content is created in
the web okay
and some people at microsoft research
took the work that i'm about to describe
and squeeze the bits down some more
getting down to about two bits per edge
so
uh you know the facetious way of looking
at it which
is the title of the paper i wanted to
write except i didn't get the result and
the guys at msr did
that the web is a two-bit graph really
right but
the the thing you should think about is
if you can really write down the web
with about two bits an edge that's the
degree of randomness
that exists in the web it's a very very
non-random graph okay
all right so what's the main idea right
so there's a bunch of ideas exploited in
the compression
and uh before i
get embark on this i want to stress that
not only do we want to squeeze the web
graph down so it fits in main memory
we also want to provide support for
queries so it's not just a matter of
running gzip for your
favorite compression algorithm okay and
the scheme that i i'll describe will in
fact
accomplish that okay so we'll make use
of the similarity between lists
okay we'll use of look make use of
locality in a certain sense that i'll
talk about and then some heavy duty
coding theory that exploits the
particular distribution
properties of certain integers we see of
these four
aspects the last two i won't really talk
about their
relatively standard coding theory the
the first two
uh are where the idea here lies okay
okay so these ideas are due to paulo
baldi and sebastian your vineyard
and and here's the basic idea you take
all the urls in the world
and order them lexicographically from
top to bottom so you start at
you know adam.com or whatever and go to
zoology.org
right and everything in between and and
you just order them lexicographically
and nothing fancier than that that's all
there is to it
okay and the key observation that
baldi and vineyard use is one of
similarity in this ordering
okay so so what's the idea uh
the observation is that because of
templating because of the way people
expect to consume
web pages because of the way people
create web pages
it turns out that the adjacency list of
every node is very similar
most of the time to one of seven
preceding adjacency
the constant 7 is not particularly
important other than it's optimizing
practice
what's important is it can be written
down in three bits it could be 15 31 etc
but in this lexicographic ordering it
takes very little space
to express yourself as similar to some
recent
url okay so so let's take an example
here if you consider the three white
adjacency lists okay so now i've
replaced all urls by integer identifiers
okay
and i'm going to look at the last one
the blue one which i hope you can see
it's a bit dark okay the observation
here
is i'm going to encode the blue
adjacency list
as follows i say look at
two adjacency lists ago that's minus two
and simply replace the nine by and eight
okay all right so what have we done here
we've used about three bits to say how
far back to look
okay and then we've written a little
local rewriting
to to get my adjacency list the claim is
most of the time this will work
most of the time you can very succinctly
write down an adjacency list in this
form
okay and if you do this right and do all
the right coding that goes with it
it takes you about three bits to write
down an edge okay
all right so what have we done here
right
so you depend heavily on this uh
kinetic ordering now nobody asked the
question why seven and not eight if i
give you three bits okay
and the reason is that every now and
then you get out of stanford.edu to a
new
domain and you don't have anybody in
recent history to write yourself
in terms of so you just start a new okay
all right so what's going on here
is that because of the behavior of page
creators because of the way
humans behave we're able to exploit
similarity in this
canonical ordering moreover this is done
in a way that adjacency queries
can be answered pretty efficiently in
order to
reconstruct an adjacency list all i need
to do
is look at this encoding so it'll point
me back somewhere and say well
look three spaces back and that might
say look five spaces back and we may
have a
chain of the sort in principle it could
get pretty bad okay
in practice it never gets bad it never
crosses four or five hops okay
that is begging for some nice theory to
explain it
okay but here's an instance that
where you not only get the compression
you also get
these very short chains that uh that
result
okay all right what's also nice is that
encoding is a simple one-pass algorithm
one you've done once you've done the
sort
okay so so that was
a quick warm-up exercise and what i'm
going to do for the
remainder of my time is strike three
themes around how consumer behavior
is is actually affecting what we compute
and how and and the three themes uh i'll
call them subjective functions
uh in contrast to the objective
functions we're always
dealing with in our business
i'll talk a little bit about data
distributions that arise from consumer
behavior
and how we should address these and
finally i'll recall the time
you know christos mentioned i was a
student here back when as a student
params are all their age
certainly i see many colleagues from
that era who
we all worked on p ramps that's not
quite how the world turned out
and i'll talk a little bit about how
parallelism works and and the different
challenges
algorithmic and theoretical challenges
that that
parallelism today demands of us
okay um so as i promised
we should the the thesis here is the
bulk
and growing fraction of of computational
resources today
are driven by by consumers
okay there's still of course lots and
lots of cycles
expanded on things like sort and select
so database operations and sorting and
so on
but a growing chunk is expanded in
this nebulous thing and and you'll see
in a moment how nebulous it gets
uh that's called we need to make users
happy okay
and and when you teach this stuff one of
the things you find is you're always in
this business of
saying well what we're really after is
user happiness but here's this proxy
that we're going to compute instead and
we're going to optimize this carefully
and we put a lot of effort into it and
you'll see a couple of simple examples
in a moment
but really this elusive thing we're
after is user happiness
right so in a sense you have
seven billion different so-called
objective functions except nobody can
write them down
and and yet we we're always computing
and optimizing proxies
for user happiness so let me take the
most
simple example so here's an example of a
subjective function so what's a good
search ranking
right this is something that many
companies worry about right
and and here's the first idea this is
about 40 years old
this is due to general sultan from
cornell university
so what he said was let's take every
document that you're going to search
and turn it into a vector in a space of
all possible terms so
to give you a sense of that all possible
terms in the web is about
a few hundred million okay so that's the
size of the vector space so in this
vector space you're casting all the
documents
so every document becomes a point in
this vector space okay
and and you can play games with exactly
where you put these points depending on
the presence or absence of terms okay
and then along comes a query which is
also a vector in this vector space and
you say well
the score is the dot product of the
query
and each document and then you pick off
the top scoring dot products okay
so we then invest a lot of energy in
computing these dot products efficiently
in data structures
for picking off the top 100 dot products
given any query
okay and you know i assure you this is
not how ranking is done today i'll
get to that in a second but this was
sort of the
the genesis of modern search ranking
about 40 years ago
okay okay
my point here is that a good search
ranking is the kind of thing consumers
are looking for but it's very hard to
write down a nice objective function of
exactly what it means
okay let me give you some more examples
okay
people want beautiful pictures of
sunsets and you say well
how do i mathematically capture a sunset
or what's beautiful
you have questions like i have several
feeds from video cameras
uh at the stadium and i want the system
to automatically
determine the best view of each of these
six cameras so there's a selection
problem there
show me songs that i like okay that's a
prototypical problem you face on amazon
rhapsody etc parenthetically i've said
spell correction spell correction turns
out to be one of the few problems
of that in this realm of user happiness
that we've actually done a pretty good
job
of mathematically characterizing
in in simple terms here's what we do we
look at the dictionary of possible words
that you could type
whether in a document or in your phone
or whatever
as a set of code words and then we build
a noisy
channel model which is often derived
from
empirical observations of how people
actually type and then it's a decoding
problem
so it's you do a maximum likelihood
estimate to figure out what the most
likely word is that
you're about to type or trying to type
right so that has a relatively clean
formulation unlike these other ones that
are far more nebulous
okay right so so here are some
characteristics of these subjective
functions that we're trying to optimize
right so
the first thing is how do we assess our
algorithm it's not like you can write
down a runtime or write down a space
bound or whatever
you end up in some sense asking users so
what does that mean
i'll show you in a couple of slides what
it means to actually ask users it's not
the case
of course that amazon or google goes and
asks every consumer
what they thought of a search ranking
but we do
learn and the key word that will keep
coming up here is learn
from consumer behavior by watching what
they click and where they go and how
much where they spend their time
okay now here's a second crucial
observation
unlike the world of traditional
algorithms
of sql and so on users have some
tolerance for junk
okay in other words absolute correctness
as heretical as this may seem absolute
correctness is not a prerequisite
if you get the wrong answer five percent
of the time it's okay as long as there
isn't somebody else out there getting it
wrong only
two percent of the time right
so and when i started working in search
this
it took me a while to understand this
that
people are okay they don't expect
perfection and that's
a characteristic of the consumer world
their experiences
are so shaped by other bad experiences
by anticipation of things that don't
work you really have to get your error
rates down
to a point where they stop noticing
okay where they stop going to parties
and talking about it okay
here's the point that christos was
alluding to when he
opened his remarks in many of these
situations
infinite computing really doesn't help
right we are not resource bound
to first order and you know the
challenge that i always pose to people
is
if we get a solution that demands lots
and lots of computing we're in great
shape because as algorithm designers
that's when we know how to bring it back
down that's our realm okay so bring it
to our domain
to our competence where resources become
the primary consideration okay and the
issue is in many of these problems
resources are not the primary constraint
right so how do we attack these problems
here's the generic approach
that that we use and
if you haven't seen this before you may
be a little shocked at how
intellectually shallow it is but this is
how it works okay
okay so so after salton did his thing
for the next 25 years until the webcam
came along here's what happened right
people worked hard
on weighting the axes in the vector
space to try and get better and better
ranking
and essentially the premise was that the
people
doing the searches weren't ordinary
consumers
there were information scientists
experts intelligence agents at
the cia in places like this who knew
exactly how to formulate a query they
had a deep understanding of the
collection of documents uh
and and so this is a very very artistic
glass bubble setting
that search ranking worked in okay
when the web came along starting about
1995 there were sea changes in how we
started thinking about search ranking so
the first thing
is that you know i think of these as
ordinary people with extraordinary
expectations they type two words
and expect magic and increasingly with
things like suggest
they type two characters and expect
magic right
and that's that's a demand especially on
mobile devices right the other thing
that hit us with the web
is adversarial content the web is an
ecosystem of
a billion people each with their own
motivations so not all of them are
interested in giving you content
that makes it easy to rank okay all
right so what do we do
okay so let's take a simple exam let's
say you're back in 1995
this this story is actually 1998. you've
been doing cosign
dot product ranking like i had several
slides ago and along comes a student
and says you know i have a new way of
scoring documents it's called page rank
right
so what do you do well you say okay i
got page rank i got this other
traditional score i got to combine them
in some fashion
okay and the problem you're left with is
combining these
in a way that makes users happy okay
and one way to do that is to set that up
as a regression problem
okay where you say well let's postulate
that what we need
is a linear combination of these and
then the way we're going to discover the
best linear combination
is to regress it to users explicitly or
implicitly express
judgments so we'll see where people
click we'll see where people abandon
searches and and try as best as possible
to retrofit
the implicit signals of user behavior
okay so in
now i said a couple of slides ago that
this is where machine learning starts to
get in
and really that is is
the state of what we do today in these
subjective function problems
so whether it's good search ranking or
likable songs or whatever
what we're doing is really we reduce the
problem to machine learning we
start trying to understand exactly what
the objective function is
okay we presume a machine learning
kernel somewhere which is at its core a
large math programming
formulation where you're trying to
minimize some
loss function and so what does an
algorithm designer end up doing in this
world
well the first thing is you invent new
signals so you come and say well i
invented page rank this other person
invented a new signal for detecting spam
or whatever
and and then hope that you get lots and
lots of data from users to train the
machine learning
and out pops a ranking function okay
there's no real explanation for why it's
0.6 times page rank plus
0.4 times cosine or whatever thing right
so
so this is a very strange world to be in
now i don't minimize some of this
because
inventing new features often entails
fairly sophisticated understanding of
how users behave
and fairly non-trivial computations in
themselves algorithmic computations but
in some sense
algorithm design in this world has been
abdicated to machine learning
right and you know again if you find
this a little heretical it's it's the
state of
how we're solving most problems today in
the consumer world
which is we're optimizing functions we
cannot even cleanly describe
right and and from an operational
methodology what we do is we come up
with a straw man solution then we get
more data and we iteratively improve and
improve and improve
and this has become a standard
methodology unless you think it's some
hack in industry
there's actually lots of very
competitive computer science conferences
where 90
of the papers are actually in this realm
okay
data volume turns out to be paramount
some of you may have heard a talk by my
colleague peter
norwig who gives you all these examples
from machine translation
spell correction that basically say the
way you win in this game is to just have
more data
okay but the the thing that
in some sense struck me the most is
algorithm designers people like myself
have stopped looking at the ram or the
turing machine as an abstraction we
instead presume
this machine learning kernel and say
okay what can we throw is by way of
features
and this is a new world which really has
been brought about
by the fact that we are not able to
cleanly characterize and succinctly
characterize what consumers want
okay all right
the last slide on this has to do with
notions we can now attack with these
methods so ending on a bit more of a
positive light
where we can start to get to straw man
notions of
even some vestiges of aesthetics right
so
so i could ask a question which of these
web pages is more appealing and
these are experiments we've done where
you take two bitmaps and present it
to machine learning algorithm and based
on user
feedback you can start to say well this
is actually more aesthetically appealing
okay john kleinberg has done work where
he says what phrases are memorable
slogans
again using the same kinds of
methodology right and then you can go
back and try to see what
would be nice is to bring back
to to the theory of perception uh and to
linguistics
what is it that makes a phrase memorable
what is it that makes
a picture beautiful memorable right
and we can do a decent job on these
problems without any pretenders or
pretense of actually understanding
aesthetics right
and certainly not of synthesizing
creativity you can say well
the way i'm going to try and produce a
beautiful page is
create 16 designs and pick the best of
them right this is not to say that we
necessarily
so so the point is we're in this funny
phase here where many of the things we
think of as
you know somehow innately human can be
machine learned and for those of you who
who have
got a background in machine learning uh
it's often the case that once you've set
up the feature spaces
the decision surfaces that you use are
relatively low degree
right it's not like you're doing
something incredibly fancy often very
low degree
decision surfaces can give you a decent
job so
this is this puzzling world where we're
not able to characterize these
functions we're trying to learn and yet
we do a decent job using fairly
simplistic
uh by some measures uh
machine learning right so so that's
what i had to say on this theme the
first theme of subjective functions
this this world where we are
attacking these consumer driven
computations
but through machinery that we didn't
learn
in graduate school this is not divided
in concurrent dynamic programming in
math programming which is sort of the
sequence that we're all
taught in algorithm design it's you know
what figure out the features and let
somebody else do the hard work
and the machine learning kernel will
write down the algorithm okay
right the second team i'm going to talk
about has to do with the data
that arises in in consumer driven
computations okay and those of you have
seen the phrase fat tales before
probably familiar with some of what i'm
going to talk about the setting that
you should probably think about is
graphs
like the web like friendship graphs that
have
low average degree but then there's a
fair number of degrees
nodes with massive degrees okay
uh okay so the term
long tail which is a misnomer was coined
by chris anderson about 10 years ago he
was the editor of wired magazine
and he would produce pictures like this
where he would say well the reason
amazon is going to beat walmart is
walmart can only store 40
000 products in its store whereas amazon
can sell a million
okay so and therefore uh
and furthermore he argued the mass in
the tail
was pretty huge and so amazon would
therefore make a lot more revenue than
uh walmart
and the same thesis was applied to books
to music etc
okay so netflix and uh blockbuster etc
okay so so he he postulated this notion
of infinite inventory stores
which in some sense get replicated also
in the graphs
that we deal with right so most products
are misses
you know not too many people want them
but in aggregate these worst sellers
account for a large fraction of sales
okay
so and then you produce impressive
statistics and
in the business world this has been
somewhat you know
received with mixed reactions and uh
in fact following anderson's initial
work we and others have done
a ton of investigation into the detail
of data some of which i'll share with
you
that on what it really uh what's really
going on here okay
all right so so the first question i
want to look at
is could the world be bimodal so maybe
there's nothing special about these
heavy tails maybe what is really going
on is
that if you look at the matrix of people
and their interests okay the movies they
watch the books they purchase etc
right there's really two distinct
populations there's normal people who
read usa today and
you know uh shop at walmart and target
and
so on and then there's the the weirdos
who
watch the bergmann movies and uh you
know
go to very specialty stores and so on uh
so one of the things that emerges when
you look at a lot of data
from from movie popularity from
search queries and so on is in fact this
is not
the real world the world real world
turns out to be much more homogeneous we
are all partially
eclectic so suddenly we turn from
weirdos to eclectic right
so interestingly every one of us
spends a lot of time in the normal zone
in the head zone
but we all make forays into
into into the tail and and if you want
more details on this there's a paper
from 2009 by broderictel that actually
details the study
okay so so in other words the world
doesn't partition into two
normal distributions or a small number
of normal distributions
there is something more going on here
okay let's look at some more data
right so so here's a picture that began
emerging uh about 15 years ago a number
of groups
including our group at ibm made this
observation
uh forget the fact it's two lines
they're red and blue they're saying
basically the same thing so i asked the
question
look at the in degrees of web pages
how is this distributed okay so i want
to draw your attention to the fact that
this
picture is log log so on both the x and
the y axis
the the the degrees are uh
plotted logarithmically and and the fact
that
you get a straight line uh you can
essentially
infer something that looks like this
you're getting like roughly an inverse
square law
on degrees okay now that is a fat tail
distribution as you can think it's not
you know a binomial or something like
that okay and and it's not the kind of
thing you would expect in an earth or
any
random graph all right right so so what
are these heavy tails so we're looking
at
probability distributions over the
integers and and what we're saying is
you pick any big number the tail mass
remains non-trivial and that's what
chris
anderson talked about and all these
pictures that's it
okay now the striking thing and
this phenomenon uh michael mitchenmacher
has a beautiful survey
that points out this phenomenon has been
observed for almost 150 years now
but in a number of settings it's the
population of cities income
distributions
uh the popularity of movies the number
of friends you have you keep
seeing these distributions so consumer
behavior recurrently
brings up these phenomena okay
so so i showed you that in degrees for
instance follow this so-called power law
okay and if you want a lot more detail
on these distributions i would urge you
to go look at
micro survey the it's a misnomer to call
them long tail distributions although
that's what
most of the public calls it because the
interesting thing is not that the tail
is long the interesting thing is that
there's a lot of probability mass on the
table
okay all right so so let's say we would
try to try
and say if erdas and reni don't explain
what's going on here if we had to
postulate
how these come up i'm going to show you
an explanation
okay which is a fairly popular
explanation but what's interesting about
this explanation
is it's also borne out in a lot of web
behavior and i'll point that out at the
end of the slide
okay so so again uh if you think of
edges arriving in sequence in a typical
random
graph model there's a parameter i'll
call it alpha
and it tells you the probability that
you come in and link to a random
webpage and with probability one minus
alpha you copy an existing
link so what does it mean to copy an
existing link you choose a web page in
proportion to its existing degree it's
equivalent
think of you're writing a paper you're
looking at citations you'll
see somebody else's paper and you copy
some of the citations over
okay that's essentially the process
we're mimicking here
now what's interesting is that on many
news
sites on the web yahoo cnn etc this
actually is exactly the process that's
going on
right they they use something called
explore exploit
where some of the time they're showing
you popular news stories
and then some other times they're
showing you a random news story just to
assess
the public popularity of this unknown
random news story
okay so explore exploit or in the
simplest form
essentially is driving these processes
okay so what happens if you run a
process like this you can write a
difference equation
that tells you how the degrees evolve
but what pops out is that
you can you can solve this and show by a
boundary difference argument
that indeed the degrees follow a power
law okay
so it's all right so that's a start uh
and this analysis is pretty old by now
and there have been improvements over
time
some colleagues at microsoft actually
took this further and tweaked the models
to better fit the web and so on
so so there's a case where some
understanding
of of human behavior does match some
observations
of web like graphs okay
right so the first thing i want to point
out here is for those of us who've been
doing probabilistic analysis of
algorithms
uh this opens up a new chapter so
consumer phenomena
yield these heavy tales okay but most
probabilistic analysis we've done
historically
uses light tail distributions because we
use simple generated models for random
graphs that say well
let's throw in an edge at random and
throw in another edge at random so on
and then we have the superposition of
independent events and
the the typical way you do this is to
say bad things seldom happen
right with fat tails bad things do
happen more often than
seldom and that's the challenge here
right so the work ahead here the first
step
is to try and analyze data structures
that we use in algorithms under heavy
tailed inputs and we've done some
preliminary work
on inverted indexes and graph
compression which are the problems that
arise
in practice and industry but i would
actually say
we really should be looking at all the
probabilistic analysis we've been doing
and rerun them with these heavy tail
distributions
not necessarily because industry is
going to use them but i think in the
process we're going to discover new
mathematical tools
that will help us move the field forward
a step further what this demands
is well i gave you a very simple
generative model and argued that it has
some vestiges
of human behavior in fact you should be
able to do better modeling analysis
of of the underlying human behavior and
this is a theme i want to pick up
from here to the end of the talk we
really should be trying to understand
what it is that motivates users
to behave the way they do and then try
to capture them
in relatively simple and clean
generative models okay
we've already observed that the behavior
of users of consumers is correlated to
each other when i copy somebody else's
behavior
when i go ask four friends which phone
did you buy and and then buy the same
thing i'm copying behavior okay
so definitely there's correlation
between users
but there's also correlations that arise
from what i'll call
market forces and i put this in quotes
because it's not the full weight of
market forces in the sense that al roth
will talk about in a few minutes
okay but let's just take the simple
setting you go to amazon or
wherever and it says you know people
like you bought these products okay
so you're influenced by that okay so
there's a graph of people and products
and you get a recommendation that's
pushed in your face now you're
thinking it's reshaped okay what does
that do to the distributions you observe
okay do you still get these fat tail
distributions we don't quite have the
analytical tools
to understand this right and in fact a
lot of things
that are somehow external to your own
behavior
start to influence uh your behavior
a particular interest is something that
journalists have started calling the
filter bubble
if you look for filter bubble on the web
you'll see a number of articles that say
things like
the internet is making us dumb because
a few companies like google and yahoo
decide what it is we see and they hide
everything else from us
okay now presumably when editors at
a major newspaper magazine decide what
you see that's okay but
if a web company does it it's not so
the the filter bubble is this name
they've given
to the fact that somehow most of the
good stuff is obscured from you because
web companies have decided you shouldn't
see anything else
and what would be interesting here is to
build plausible models
of behavior as affected by
recommendation systems
and then try and argue that no well yes
there is a fitter bubble
no there isn't and that would be a nice
observation sequence of observations
on human behavior
okay uh the last segment of my talk
today
switches to parallelism
many of you probably heard this
misattributed quote to thomas watson
senior the founder
of ibm that uh the world maybe had a
market of six computers this was
supposedly in the earl 50s
i traced it back and the nearest person
i could find
saying any such thing was howard aiken
actually
and in a strange way i would say we're
almost in this world of six computers
today
okay and you say what do you mean i have
three computers in my backpack
uh but but there is a sense in which
there's six or ten or maybe 20 computers
in the world today which is
the the clouds operated by the major
service companies whether it's you know
ibm or microsoft or google or whatever
and really what you're carrying in your
backpack is a display device okay
and so this is sort of transformed our
thinking
in terms of what is it we do with this
cloud we have these
thousands hundreds of thousands millions
of machines and
and this seems like a dream come true
for pram designers except it didn't
quite pan out that way right so for
those of you who
who are old enough you'll remember these
things called p-ramps we sat and
we all designed algorithms for them uh
so
it was a nice simple abstraction we had
shared memory
we very fine-grained computation things
were very synchronous the world moved in
lockstep
machines never died and in principle
programming was very
straightforward okay and then some of us
certainly myself
we went off and started looking at
networks of fixed topology we said well
you know nobody can really build a
p-ramp but we can build a hypercube or a
cube-connected cycle or something like
this
and we started designing these very
elaborate and
in retrospect very brittle algorithms
for making use of them
right we never thought about what
happens if one node of a hypercube dies
uh presumably everything dies right
les valiant told me it's more than 20
years since he proposed the bull
synchronous
parallel model bsp i didn't realize it
was quite that long ago
but less this model was really a
forerunner
of of what we end up using today
right in the reality of today we have
four tall fault prone processes by the
time you assemble
a cloud with a million processes a few
are going to die every hour
right synchrony is coarse grained there
is no notion of
lock step there's no notion of a global
clock that keeps all your
machines in sync in fact some of them
will occasionally
time out for this reason or that okay
locality of data access does matter
and here's a killer that most of us
didn't really realize
that
you may pay a thousand dollars for a
machine but then you pay
a hundred thousand dollars maintaining
it i mean that ratio seems
a little off but certainly software
development
and maintenance costs uh
far dominate the cost of hardware and so
in some sense what we want our paradigms
for amortizing that over a huge number
of machines and keeping the programming
abstractions very very simple
now in our realm in the consumer realm
we want to solve problems such as switch
search queries co-occur or which friends
to recommend or which
products or whatever right and so so i
want you to keep that in mind as i go
through the next
few slides on on the reality of
parallelism right
one other thing i made this comment on
on software development being a killer
which is a little hard for us to
model and abstract in theory but
the standard solution if you had
something like a pram was
would be to use threaded programs and if
any of you have done done any threaded
programming it's it's a nightmare
to to actually debug and run these
things okay the next couple of slides
uh i've borrowed from sergey
vasilevitsky my
colleague who with some other colleagues
has actually been trying to build
something of a theory
for these map reduce style con
computation so so mapreduce
is a paradigm for parallel programming
that has come to dominate
the the way we do consumer parallel
computation
in in the real world okay the way to
think about it is a
lot of the hard work of keeping machines
alive checking who's dead
moving jobs around is left to an
underlying library
in the cloud that's taking care of all
of this and as as a
programmer all you have to do is specify
two functions called map and reduce and
i'll explain the roles in a second
okay so all the stuff about data
distribution synchronization etc
is left to the mapreduce runtime system
but in turn this restricts you to a
certain stylized view of parallel
computing you don't have arbitrary
pram power okay certain kinds of
parallelism are
allowed and one of the things that is
just starting off and
i i want to point to as a rich area for
further work
is to build a stronger theoretical
foundation for these map-reduced styles
of computation
okay all right so so a couple of basics
so
you look at all data in key value pair
so
that's the only way you're going to
manipulate data in mapreduce okay
so for instance a graph you think of it
as a list of edges
where the keys are the edge names and
the values
are the weights okay and and essentially
you have three really map and reducer
the primary two
programmers view steps okay so the map
function
essentially takes a key value pair and
then
with shuffle aggregates all the pairs of
the same keys so all
attributes of a given edge are sent
into one bucket okay
here's another example you can say
you have a bunch of documents you're
parsing them
then you can say that i want to map
together
all documents or document ids that
contain a particular word
okay this is a routine step in in
constructing a search engine
okay and then in the reduced phase you
you can do things like well
now that i've gathered all the guys all
the document
ids containing a given term given word
into one processor
i can sort them out to create an
inverted index for instance
okay so so the map phase distributes the
data around
to reducers as they're called and the
reducers then finish up the work okay
now between these distribution steps
there's a lot of local computation going
on so i don't want you to think of this
as one clock cycle there's lots of clock
cycles going on
and then one distribution step and then
a reduction step
okay and and so the environments one
deals with
you have tens could be tens of thousands
uh this is not just you don't have to
work at google to do this if you're an
academic you many academics i know
do this using uh for instance amazon's
cloud services
okay right now even if you have a
terabyte size data set
your machines your basic nodes only have
about gigabytes of memory so forget
trying to get
all the data into memory this is good
for batch processing
so it's not something that you do for
serving queries for instance it's really
something you do offline
okay now if it helps you think about it
and this is not material to what
i'm about to say next right think of
sublinear memory per machine
and a number of machines that sub linear
in
in the input size okay so computation
produces in these
proceeds in these map reduce rounds and
typically you're looking for a constant
number of rounds but within a round a
lot of stuff goes on
okay right so i'm going to give you a
simple example
of how you might try
to do something we want to do a lot this
if you have a social graph for instance
you want to do things like count
triangles okay and then show you how
things can go bad here
because of the data distributions that
arise in practice because of fat tails
and then how simple fix fixes it okay
so if you want to count triangles in a
graph what you do one way of doing it
sequentially is each node looks at its
neighborhood and then tries to count up
the triangles it's involved in
and the run time in this case every
triangle gets counted three times
is the sum of the degree squared okay
and in practice this will be quadratic
because of these heavy tails
some vertices will have very high degree
okay
all right so here's a naive parallel
version you generate all possible path
two pairs so
here i am i'm sitting here i look at my
two neighbors okay
send all these paths that include me in
the middle to a reducer
that then checks if if a triangle can be
completed and then sum up
okay the problem with this is that the
fat tails
strike again because the reducer that
takes
the high degree node in the middle takes
forever to complete so
one of the things you observe when you
run these things is the first few
reducers
finish really fast 90 of the work is
done in a few minutes and then the whole
thing can take 20 hours okay
so so you see why fat tails hit us again
here
okay and i've given you some
representative numbers here so data's q
in particular the fat tail defeats naive
parallelization now here's a very
trivial modification of that algorithm
that suddenly turns out to magically
work right so instead of counting each
triangle three times
just make the lowest degree vertex in
each triangle
count the triangle and the others ignore
it okay that seems like a trivial
modification should only save a factor
of three
in fact it wins okay so
so why does it work well let's partition
our nodes into two groups
the high nodes and the low nodes the
high nodes are the ones with large
degree
bigger than square root of m where m is
the number of edges okay there's not
that many of them
okay and the crucial observation is that
only about m
of these paths where a high node is in
the middle
right because you look at my
neighborhood at the
the total number of high nodes is only
about root n right
okay so the total number of paths from
high nodes is m to the three halves
for the low nodes it's your sum i
squared times
and i can show that to be m to the three
halves again so the total work
is m to the three halves which is the
best you can do but what about parallel
runtime
okay what's neat here is the algorithm
when you do it this way
automatically load balances because it
only sends things to the lower degree
node lower degree nodes in each triangle
and as a result the maximum number of
paths
any reducer has to check is m okay
and so instead of taking 27 hours
everybody is done in five minutes
okay so fat tails get tamed by the
seemingly trivial modification
and the reason i want to stress this is
again
my earlier point when you're doing
parallel computation to this realm
think about the data distribution and
that shapes how you think about
algorithms
okay and and the per round run times
come down dramatically
okay so let me just finish with some
closing thoughts right so so as i said
ordinary users consume a growing share
of computation
cycles storage etc and their
expectations
reshape the computational problems we
pursue
right so when we when i spoke of
problems like
you know give me songs i like that's not
a problem i found in gary and johnson
right but that's a problem we have to
solve right uh
the behavior of users and this is sort
of the really subtle part that
i think will take us years to figure out
reshapes the data distributions we
observe
you know i gave you very superficial
explanations for how
copying like behavior gives fat tails
but that's just
the tip of the iceberg right we really
need to
get deeper into understanding this and
and this recaps how we
think about and and teach algorithms uh
certainly we have to learn all the
classic paradigms but now in this new
world
i think uh algorithmic thinking has to
undergo an evolution
okay i think this comes with
tremendous challenges and benefits to
computer science and
perhaps to the social sciences more
importantly
one of the things that we're constantly
hampered by in our industry
is we don't have people who understand
user behavior and
large data and algorithms right so the
the caricature i have is
we don't have psychologists who can
write mapreduce programs right
and and really if you go past the
caricature i think the
opportunity here is for us to start to
understand human behavior
on a scale that we never used to before
because your typical social science
experiment
involves tons of people but at the same
time
uh so so you have the scale of computer
science coming in
the machines and so on but hopefully
with the depth of thinking
that social scientists have dedicated
hundreds of years to
i'm certainly not qualified to think
hard about
exactly how human behavior works out so
so i think combining these two should
create really fertile
directions and it certainly behooves
institutions like the simons to promote
this kind of work on campus and i hope
to see a lot more of it
because it will benefit us all thank you
josh
is there enough data to do that
yeah so josh's question was would the
data
be too sparse to train on individuals
right so what we end up doing
is we sort of have global model models
that dis
describe population as a whole then we
have segments
that implicitly or explicitly correspond
to recognizable segments of
you know teens versus elderly retired
versus whoever right
uh and then sometimes uh you go further
down by saying okay
this person really seems to like both uh
philosophy and uh
you know computer science or whatever
and and you you're tuned to that so it's
really
a hierarchy and at the higher levels
obviously you have more data and have
more confidence
uh and and the danger of over fitting
with sparse data of course is you bug
users
who say well i you know my my grandson
borrowed my
iphone and did a query and now i'm
getting you know inundated with whatever
teen pop or something right
um
okay so you're setting me up here right
because uh so the question is well
what if galileo had access to machine
learning and he
you know threw in the color of the balls
he was tossing from the leaning tower
uh as a feature uh uh could he get all
confused
yeah yeah i was at a meeting uh
in washington dc when someone came along
and suggested
that we should forget climate science
and instead replace it by machine
learning model that just took the last
two years of weather and tried to
predict tomorrow's weather now that
would be a mistake because
if you have hundreds of years of
understanding that's always preferable
to to a new feature right the trouble in
many of these situations
is we don't have a lot of understanding
for the reasons i said you know we don't
have deep social science understanding
and second
uh the consumer world is not stationary
in in the in the stochastic sense it
keeps evolving
so yesterday's models don't necessarily
work well next year right
and for that reason we we don't always
have time to settle down with sound
understanding of consumer behavior
and realize that the color of the
clothes somebody is wearing isn't a good
feature
right uh and so it is true that we
probably place too much
emphasis on on on the power of the model
and not enough on understanding and
part of my appeal here is let's try and
put more wood
behind the the more the the underlying
behavior
uh before we get too caught up in this
but this is all we have for now
yeah so you end your talk with uh
the grand challenge in the day today of
understanding human behavior on a scale
that never before possible
i humbly suggest that our
challenge is in fact to understand the
behavior of life
on earth not just at this time
okay i think
that's a very fair comment uh it's
probably the case we'll begin first with
humans but there are certainly uh uh
well
in his talk john kleinberg didn't talk
about non-human behavior but there's
people in this
field broad field of so-called network
science that are actually looking at
you know food chains and uh you know
other aspects of of networks so so i'd
say we're still scratching the surface
and it's it's very wide open at this
point
yeah we talked about
the difference in the filter bubble and
the new york times
so first of all everybody understands
the new york times has an editorial
and when they search they think they're
in a sort of informational
commons and if they don't understand
that
right i think what cynthia's pointing
out is that
there's different forms of trust
engendered by the new york times versus
say
google a bing or somebody right the new
york times has a storied history of
of trustworthy reporting and editorial
culling and people have grown to depend
on that as
a definitive source of truth with search
engines
it's it's it's a little more random for
sure
there's this black box that
whereas you're saying that when you
elect to buy the new york times
you've elected to get the liberal
that's right uh so so that's a path that
frankly we have to tread on very
carefully the degree of personalization
uh that you're talking about the liberal
view you know for a search engine
is i think at the point of being
technical feasible but we're all sort of
skittish about doing anything
like that uh simply because of
of the concerns it'll raise amongst the
people who understand as opposed to the
people you're talking about who may not
even realize
that they're being liberated
uh well so you know we're not trying to
do that as far as i know
yeah to continue along this line
could you presumably um cluster
viewpoints and then build you know get
the top
three or something and then build in
buttons that
you can
yeah yeah so so here's something that uh
some years ago we did as an april fool's
joke uh when i was at yahoo
we we put up a search bar and there was
a red button on the right with an
elephant and a blue button on the left
with
a donkey and you could click either and
you'd either get blue links or red links
and it was an april fool's joke and it
was done as a complete hack
but people took it very seriously and
got really upset right
and and so it's not something that i
think any search engine would do lightly
but technically what you're saying is
feasible
you mentioned that the challenge for
algorithm
analysis is to
analyze algorithms under these new
distributions
would it be more interesting and more
scientific if
instead of taking the distributions
go to the organic generated models and
try to analyze algorithms for generated
models
implicitly that's what you want to do
because eventually when you do the
analysis
you're not presuming the distribution
you're going to the underlying
generative models that's how you end up
doing the analysis
so yeah that's absolutely what you do
now you have to believe in the
generative model
beyond yeah it seems to produce the
right distribution and that to me is a
leap of faith
again taking on this this data bias
issue
i mean i think there is this peculiar i
have to worry about the self
the solipsistic self reference getting
out of hand
so give an example computer vision
systems are being trained
with images that have been retrieved
from google search
and so there were certain kinds of
images on which those systems worked
and were retrieved because recall is
always lower
and now he has become happy because we
can do well like that
of course there is this important matter
that we are ignoring
so so jithendra's objection is that
computer version is trained on images
obtained
from an image search engine on the web
right uh
and is that good science and of course
it's not good science but on the other
hand you compare it with the bulk of
what's
happened in the social sciences i don't
know how many of you have read
the recent discussion on so-called weird
people
anybody heard of weird people so weird
is this acronym that stands for western
educated uh
industrialized something something and
essentially it points out that most
social science research is done on
undergraduates in north america
okay so is that a bias yeah i would
argue that's a bias and hopefully not as
frightening as
so we're taking steps in the right
direction i would agree we're not all
the way there
okay thank you very much thanks